so remember I said to you before that
they tell you there are tangents here in
fact I've drawn them over there on the
right hand side I've said this a few
times but when you've got a diagram
that's just a mess of things it often
helps to draw like sort of subsidiary
diagrams with less things on them just
the features that you're most interested
in so you can see it a little more
clearly that's kind of clearing the fog
a little bit now here are the tangents I
want you guys to just throw stuff out
what kinds of that you know a lot of
things in relation to tangents what can
you talk about tangent don't worry about
whether it's relevant or not just tell
me anything you know about tangents
related to a circle yeah reading
anything absolutely if you yep fantastic
so if we have a line from the center of
the circle to the tangent we know
there's there perpendicular that's good
we know more stuff tell me what else you
know we're nursery stuff we're similar
triangles attendants don't we do you
remember stuff with ratios it's actually
it's the longest and most Awkward of all
of the properties which is saying
something because some of them are
pretty long and awkward this property
here do you remember this one if you've
got a X B Q we say this square of the
intercept on the tangent which is x
squared equals the product of the
intercepts on the secant which would be
in this case P and P plus Q okay that's
very long and awkward but it's true and
it's another tangent piece of
information okay I'm the one that really
you mentioned will look like this I
guess
tangent Center do we know anything else
about tangents
ah
okay now yes now this one's really
tricky because this property is about
tangents but it doesn't even have codes
along or curve we abbreviate it and the
abbreviation doesn't even have the word
tangent in it which is is one of the
downsides of abbreviating that we forget
it relates to the tangents it's this
property I have drawn up tangent a s to
this circle this is the left hand circle
okay and because I've got this tangent
over here if I formed this line oh not
with this marker if I formed this line
over here then the angle between the
tangent and the do you know this this is
a chord right but it has a special name
because it touches the tangent does
anyone remember we didn't talk about it
very much
we call it the court of contact okay
because this court is in contact with
this tangent okay so the angle between
the tangent and the court of contact
what is it equal to
it's the it's the it is interior is
opposite we use actually a different
phrase we'll see how there's this
segment over here and then this this
other segment so the word for that is
alternate right so this guy over here is
the angle in the alternate segment and
that's what we call this property
because the rest of it is so long okay
so when you have a tangent and you've
got a chord that touches the tangent you
can say this in the right-hand circle
you can say the same thing all right
if you form an a court of contact here
then this angle will equal the angle
Neill turret segment like so okay now
the reason why I drew these in
particular is because remember when we
were trying to say oh I'm trying to
prove this is a diameter this should
show me that that's 90 degrees do you
remember that so that's why I'm
interested in this angle which is why I
drew it over here okay so watch what
happens when we put that you know I've
did those many diagrams I'm gonna
transfer them over here this angle angle
ap R is the angle in the alternate
segment which is the angle I should just
put one because I'll keep it consistent
with those diagram
which is the angle that is the between
the tangent the top court of contact
which angle is it can you see where it
belongs
Ras okay where is that ah a s so that's
this guy do you agree so this is the and
it's very hard to see when you've got so
much stuff going on here you have to or
you almost have to draw another diagram
right this is the angle between the
tangent in the court of contact and this
is the angle in the alternate segment so
they should both be theta is that all
right but but wait a second
see how I drew this diagram down here in
the other circle with the other tangent
what's this angle here have a look it's
s AR which hold on a second has the same
angle is the same angle just looked at
from two different perspectives so s a
are now looking at this circle over here
is equal to the angle in the alternate
segment you can see it I've labeled it a
Q s do you see a Q s so that tells you
but you just found it was theta and I
already have it equal to something else
what that means that both of these are
equal does that make sense and we're
pretty much there now okay because
remember what we were trying to prove we
were looking we were searching for a
right angle so if this is true and
obviously you have a lot of reasoning
there's going to be a few lines in here
then I can say theta equals 180 degrees
minus theta I can add theta to both
sides and that gives me the right angle
I was searching for okay
so my final lines will be this is 90
degrees mm-hmm therefore aar is a
diameter because the angle of a
semicircle is 90 degrees so that's my
reason okay now say to Russell before
how long did it take me to see this it
didn't take as long to see it as to
explain it but it took me some time
mainly because I was trying to draw
things I was trying to see the question
in new ways in an exam what do you do
you look at a question if you know when
you have reading time I advise you look
at the circle geometry first
just look at it look at the properties
do you see something straightaway
if you do that's amazing good buy a
lottery ticket but if you don't no
problem your brain will keep working on
it
in the background okay if you get then
get through the exam you get to this
question and you still don't see it
do not waste your time just staring at
it look at it for like maybe a minute if
you see something that you can make
progress with great if not move on come
back because these questions can really
be they'll just take as much time you
could spend the whole paper on this
question sorry the whole exam time on
this question and still not get it out
because you just it doesn't appear okay
so just be smart with your exam time